the first world war
there were only 21 persons allowed to be
members of the press corps at any time
i have to have a syndicate of smaller
newspapers that got me in
we all jumped up
and went over the top
and i felt no fear i felt
instead it was tremendous
and then our barrage stopped
and then the great surprise of my life
it was total silence there was nothing
there
and this is the first time that anybody
who wasn't committed
to
bolshevism got into russia
you see and all of us flocked in there
and of course the first thing we wanted
to see was
the interview of course was lenny
we tried to interview him what you might
call on the run in this push and someone
started out by saying you speak english
oh what a question to ask a great man
and he said i speak him
the english language that's a very good
that was his answer which was all
right this is uh this is my friend
mussolini who continued to call me
carol kalego on every occasion that i
met him on the february 29th i'll never
forget the date because he said look i
forgot it was leap year i have no i have
no appointments
i kept asking him so i'll talk to you
for hours i have nothing to do today and
he talked to me for a couple hours
george seldis former foreign war
correspondent and premier press
muckraker who's been suppressed by the
establishment media makes his tv debut
tonight on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when the late editor of the nation
magazine
carrie mick williams was asked to name
the 10 greatest muckrakers in the
history of american journalism
he named a few names that we're all
probably familiar with
people like lincoln stefans
upton sinclair
iaf stone
ralph nader
but there was one name
that
most of you are probably not familiar
with
george seldes
don't feel too embarrassed
george seldis is a man who's lived in
the shadows of american journalism a
giant living in the shadows of american
journalism
why haven't you heard of him
well for most of his journalistic career
he's been
you might call it a marked man
boycotted blacklisted by the american
press establishment why well he went
after the press itself he was the
press's critic
tonight
at age 90
george seldes
will get his american television
debut
at the end of his life lincoln stephens
perhaps the quintessential knock raker
himself
ended up becoming very disenchanted with
muckraking
he thought that
perhaps they were missing the real point
and he said that
all these stories about corruption
essentially
don't question the underlying system
was there any philosophy that
underlay your criticism
any social or political philosophy
nonetheless your criticism of
establishment journalism i believe in
revisionist history i believe that
history is largely written wrong which
i'm not the original
uh
i didn't originate that phrase you know
i mean
i mean napoleon said so metaphorian said
history's lies agreed upon
you know
and things like that
well i mean
the month breakers have i think to some
extent made a living on on
revising history now that last book of
mine which is called even the gods
cannot change history
is supposed to tell the facts which were
wrong in the books but you are a
reporter that has spent his life trying
to keep us all abreast of the difference
between fact and fiction
but you have a story to tell us in your
first experience with the press and its
role in myth making in world war one in
the first world war
there were only 21 persons allowed to be
members of the press corps at any time
g2 was intelligence we were g2d which
meant we were the press department
of the intelligence department very well
so i was one of the lucky people all the
rest were important people like irvine s
cobb damon runyon william allen white
george patello william slavins mcnutt
collier's sad evening post all these
notable names were there i have to have
a syndicate of smaller newspapers that
got me in
well
i was brought i was my experience was on
a small newspaper and i knew about
what the press was up to and all like
that i wasn't taken in by the grandeur
of the great names and the great people
maybe that's one of the reasons
why i'm telling you the story perhaps
well anyway i
i think i mentioned the fact that uh
that in july the 18th the american
troops
led by the marines by the way given full
credit they're actually led by the
second division of which the marines
were only half but the marines got
credit for everything always do you know
uh smashed the hindenburg line and when
we saw him later he admitted this was
the decisive day of the war the american
was the first time our lines had been
broken and you can say that that was the
american troops which won the war i
don't think he used the phrase won the
war but would change the tide of the war
that's the phrase he used very well
flush called in
um
hershey and said look i have brilliant
idea why don't you find american fresh
troops which have had this terrific
victory
you see they're now marching towards
germany and the war by a wonderful
uh pinscher movement
this is the sami el salien and he called
it a dagger appointed at the heart of
france he says why don't we attack at
the two
edges of this alien see and and join our
armies there trap a hundred thousand
germans in san miel you see liberate
sambiel the first time to be town to be
liberated after four years of war
and already trapped the german army and
immediately turn our troops and he had a
great idea for getting all the way to
the rhine well pershing was very pleased
with it and
we all went and got ready it took us
till september about the 11th to get
ready for this one and that had a signal
either 4 30 or 5 or the book i say 5 we
were all to go over the top
on these two sides
cross no man's land converge our armies
and trap the germans and capture samuel
well there i was you see the youngest
member of the army by the way of the
press section
uh herbicide 1928 i was 28. i was uh
1918 i was 28. well there we were in the
trenches this is not my first time i've
been in the rainbow division i think i
told you one day that my first night in
the trenches and it was a normal night
where nothing happens like invest in
these snowy issues no nothing happened
except that on the trench next to the
one which i was in i was with the ohios
a shell happened to break through the
cover
and there were eight men in the dugout
officers and men they were all killed
and just that shell fell 20 feet from
our dugout that's that's nothing
happened that night you see but this was
the greatest barrage we'd ever put over
you see and there i was thinking i was a
coward i think i had my life i've always
thought
if i came to some physical
decision i might be a coward i might run
away i might not face it i've never had
an experience like this i mean it's all
right to steal
pictures off the wall of somebody you're
interviewing you know or the man who
committed suicide in a newspaper or
something that but this was a great test
you know
and so i was there and i tell you that i
think the main thing is mass psychology
i was there with all the dough boys i
mean the whole rainbow division i think
we were all
in a way
i mean they say the good soldier must
feel fear
we were all trembling with fear perhaps
but when the moment said go over the top
and
you realize that for four years anybody
that showed a hand over the top or let
alone his head got it blown off
we all jumped up
and went over the top
and i felt no fear i felt exhilaration
instead it was tremendous
and then our barrage stopped
and then the great surprise of my life
it was total silence there was nothing
there
after all these years there was no reply
from the germans there was nothing
there was no man's land we walked
wherever we wanted i found we found the
ruins of a plane that had been shot down
earlier an old tank turret shot out or
something they got to the german
trenches we admired how well they lived
they even had electric lights in their
trenches they lived well you know at
least the officers did and we went
across
and
nothing happened so i said well you know
we were on the pictures that was 20 you
know that was if samia was there we were
up 50 miles away or something you see so
i said this is no good i'll never get
there and of course being one of the
lucky people in the press section i had
a cadillac that wasn't only time in my
life i ever did i had a cadillac and a
sergeant who drove it and all that
that's what the 21 of us each ranked the
cadillac
and i went and got my driver
and
i said look
let's drive back and try to get into san
diego
and then he was the brilliant man he
said look everybody's going to try to do
it now we know that all the roads are
mine and when they're not mine there are
tank traps now look here's what we will
do let us drive around we have the time
let us drive
around and make a detour
and then come
to on samuel from another section north
of the town you see where they never
expected anybody to come from
and maybe they will get in there and he
drove around to a town called chauvin
cooper which was northwest
when we came to shove we found a trap in
the town the main road went through the
top
the tank trap was a hole
between the houses so that nobody could
get through but we were practically in
san mio there so we left the car on the
other side of the tank trap
you see
we walked across
we walked on the side street where no
carpet a little narrow street we got to
the river booze or as general christian
called with the muzz
we got there
and to our there was some yell in front
of us and to our great surprise we found
french colonial work troops
building a plank bridge into the town
where the big bridge had been destroyed
and they were sort of blue fatigue or
whatever it was so they had been there
before us and
nevertheless being the
correspondence dressed in practically an
officer's uniform you know we didn't
have those who did wore the whole sam
brown belt but those who felt queasy
about it left off the shoulder strap
just a belt around here but an officer's
uniform we got there and they all
thought hurrah they said who are you are
you germans you're wearing a brown
uniform
we said no we're the americans well when
they heard americans they gave us
the grand ovation and then we said well
where are the germans they said the
germans have been gone for almost two
weeks
so here general pershing and forsh and
all our great intelligence
had made this greatest attack with the
greatest expenditure of ammunition we'd
ever made with tanks and preparation i
think that patton's tanks were in the
back of us and all that
and there wasn't one german there they
had at least 10 days earlier pulled out
and there was nobody in san diego but
the few french colonials building a
bridge which we crossed and the whole
town turned out in the in in the center
you see
and gave us the reception
two hours later general pershing who had
got caught in one of those tank traps or
you know or mines or something
eventually got there with the secretary
of uh
the war newton d baker
with general pet town who was the
commander of that front
uh who forged sans
and uh clemencel was supposed to meet
him there too but he got lost you know
and worst of all the us
signal core which was supposed to take
movies of the triumphal entry of san
miel never got there at all so the
photographs i took these few stills on a
little camera that i brought with me i
think it was about two inches by three
inches in plates by the way uh the only
the the only
historical evidence of perching walking
across the plank two hours after i was
there into the town well you could never
repeat this great celebration for
pershing
you see which they gave us however they
the mayor the chief of police and some
of the people who had been in hiding and
came from elsewhere and there was a few
speeches made at the city hall and
honored well i told them who pershing
was they didn't even know his name the
germans didn't tell them much about our
the american army being there
well the main point is this
that despite the fact that there was no
capture stunning capture
storming of san mio
i told you what there was there we went
to no man's land nothing
and no triumphal entry because certainly
the edge had been taken off
uh
the story was a table to america
samuel captured american troops greatest
victory in the whole war uh general
pershing's triumphal entry samuel to
this very day
it appears in books because
a professor i can't think of his name
just now but i have letters from him
as late as a year or two ago a man wrote
a history of the first world war or
something in which he uses a story and i
wrote to him and he said well if i ever
if it's ever a second edition i should
certainly correct it you say
i told them what happened you see
well what happened also was this
i told you we were briefed
as to how we were going
to put over this terrific barrage the
greatest barrage of the war
and destroy everything in front of us
and then come out and then perhaps
engage in hand-to-hand battle with the
germans after we had destroyed their
trenches and eventually march and join
up the two american armies and trapped
them there well we were briefed and it
was fox connor i told you the chief of
operations and general nolan gave us the
story
and he said at so and so at 4 30 the
barrage will start at five o'clock we go
over the top at 5 10 15 we should have
reached this point at 5 35
well among the bright boys of our of the
press corps freddie ferguson
of the united press did the very clever
thing
you can't say it was a false story
because what he did was to take the
briefing
at 4 30 we shall start the box barrage
all he did was at 4 30 the box
the barrage now
is a small one he meant the full length
of the front barrage at 4 30 the barrage
will start
so he put down at 4 30 we started the
barrage at five o'clock all our men the
rainbow known mentions them you know we
are allowed to mention the visions of
that day went over the top etc he just
put it that ever happened now he didn't
try to sneak it through or break the
censorship
he went to the censor who was named was
captain gerald morgan
and he said captain
the censor he says look here are here is
the story in what journalists call takes
in short pieces
dated you see by our just as
[ __ ] as uh
dennis nolan's general roland said we
were going to do it when the word i
meant to be able to get back here you
see nobody's to write the story besides
i wouldn't have time as
headquarters announces our progress you
release these takes one by one
naturally headquarters announced the
barrage
the jumping into no man's land the
advancing and eventually general
pershing's triumphal entry to samuel and
one by one
the gerald morgan the censor released
ferguson's dispatch written in the past
tense of the glorious capture of samuel
and to this very day this is the story
that historians accept
and they will not accept the story of
the one person who was there who says
there was no capture there was no
storming there was no glory sentry
etcetera etcetera persian himself
further added insult to the truth
by
perhaps shading in this issue of the
capture of german troops would you tell
that part of that
an interesting that happened
you don't expect now look what you do
not expect is that that the american
army official communicate with saying we
entered samuel today and found that the
germans had left it at least 10 days ago
that the orders to withdraw had been
issued two weeks earlier now you don't
expect us to admit that ever see but
that's exactly what happened
now pershing eventually
and
and sending his own dispatches you see
says this glorious victory of whatever
he calls it you see resulted in the
capture of tens of thousands of german
infantry
artillery men
guns ammunition everything else trains
all of which was true why was it true
because
apparently at least two weeks or maybe
earlier ludendorff
i told you the general officers are the
whoever wins the war is because they're
somewhat less stupid than the other
general headquarters ludendorff at
general headquarters i'm not saying
hindenburg hinderberg was a bright man
but lutendorf and general headquarters
they had perhaps decided they certainly
had decided to reinforce on the elf even
either before they knew or maybe after
they knew we were going to attack it
and so they had dispatched
i don't know at least ten thousand or
more ten
no 10 000 would only be a couple of no
they did this perhaps 10 divisions of
men
you see we we captured i think 10 or 20
000 men there
they had divisions of men with whole
trains and munitions and artillery were
dispatched to set to keep san miguel and
they kept coming and a day or two after
we were in town
trains started coming in over the
railroad from
the north they were coming in from the
german side they'd been on their way
they continued on their way they landed
at the railroad stations instead of
being greeted with the mach damn rhine
or gut midtones they found the american
troops that says buses to your lows or
something and they said put your hands
up your prisoners the americans well
some of them very happy about it
after four years of or more
but nevertheless that's how we captured
these tens of thousands of prisoners
they simply walked into our book they
wrote in a railroad trains and that is
the whole story of sanmiel i swear to
you this is the fact
not a single life was lost not a person
was hurt and or if anyone fell off the
plank bridge they might have hurt his
leg is about all i know of in the way of
um
a thing certainly it bears out that old
axis
certainly bears out that old axiom in
war the the truth is the first case
is the first casualty lord possibly
that's his title of the book
george you've uh covered the noted and
notorious you knew lenin
tell us your impressions of you met when
you met lenin
whether you like it or not
lenin was the man who cha who
changed the course of this century more
than any other person that i know of
i think it's be admitted
i mean napoleon may have changed the
18th century
i mean for good or evil but
so it was lending i mean after all uh
his interpretation of uh marx which they
called communism of first bolshevism
certainly spread throughout the large
part of the
world and they're still influencing the
world although
uh i mean
i think lately i mean with the defection
of tito with the first great break in
1948 and then of course the biggest
nation of all china
uh not accepting marx i mean there's
stalinism there's been a great change
nevertheless you might say that the
that the that the leninist or the
putting into practice
the 19th century philosophy of karl marx
changed the century
well
everybody in the world was
wanting to go in
to
interview lemmy you know
and uh
almost no one ever did
i remember uh
telegrams to the chicago tribune that's
the kind of telegrams you that that
drove us into ulcers uh
proceed
you know interview lemming or proceed
moscow before they start running
excursion cranes you know clayton who
was in uh finland trying to get in
he thought he'd quiet them up in chicago
he sent them a bill for three reindeer
shot from under me while trying to cross
the frontier
into russia
well
luckily the hoover relief
administration which saved at least 6
million russian lives maybe 10 so that
all the russian leaders today really owe
their lives to america they were the
children
who are food saved and thanks her the
herbert hoover the man who fed belgium
fed the russians you know there's no
trace of this appeared in any russian
book stalin are limited
eliminated at all you ca you mentioned
hoover or famine there was no mention of
even a famine they never have famine
under the bolshevik regime you know
the fact is the peasants shall still be
enemies and they're still sabotaging and
they're having frequent famines they
still have to buy grain in america
well anyway
mr walter lyman brown was a
representative of mr hoover's
and in the treaty with mr lavina
by which we were permitted to enter
russia to save their lives
it was specified that newspapermen have
the right to go in
and this is the first time that anybody
who wasn't committed
to
bolshevism got into russia
you see and all of us flocked in there
and of course the first thing we wanted
to see was
the interview of course was lenny well
lenina had a this was a 1922.
see and i remember very well
november the 7th 1922 would have been
the fifth anniversary
of the russian
revolution
and um there was a
meeting
i don't know the delegates of all the
communist nations or the common turn or
something it was in the hall of the
czars in the kremlin
and i remember oh the czar's throne had
been put back in the background and
there were all the leaders you know
trotskyians and all the if and communism
they were all sitting there you see
and uh
talk about cleverness the
the
the soldiers at each door there was a
soldier with a rifle see
an illiterate soldier chosen especially
because he couldn't read or write you
know why because by his side there was a
panel
and but on the panel
there were sample cards
of delegates and members and journalists
etc etc all of whom would be permitted
to enter
you see and nobody else
and
say
this was the diocese of which they were
all sitting it was above us about three
steps up and here were the two tables
with the press and we were about say 20
feet
from the first door coming in
and
i have we all sort of looked up there's
a little trouble but one of the
policemen
see one of the guards with the rifle he
was holding up a man the man didn't have
the right car to come in and yet he
wanted to come in
well we looked you'll never believe your
eyes it was
illegitimate
illegitimate himself
he had recovered from his first stroke
the doctor said he was capable of making
a speech
apparently he didn't have the right card
for the day and he couldn't get in
so of course they got him in and i
remember this
which it's typical of something of the
man's great character
as he went zanombie was speaking when
all this was taking place so nobody was
the one who spoke in a high false set of
voices and we all hated him
he shrieked or something
and
as he came by us to go up this three
steps to mount you see he had to come by
the press table
and he's heard genomics speaking and as
he went by us i looked and he was
tiptoeing not to make a noise to disturb
the speech now that's a great man in a
way in a little episode that unlikes a
man's character as channing said more
than a whole book of biography
and of course then as soon as they
recognize him
what you might say in the old days was
pandemonium but was broke loose again it
was terrific
and then he got up and he made a speech
and he spoke for an hour
in russian then he spoke
for an hour in german in the same speech
i think a third time in french i'm not
sure about the french but i remember him
pausing for a german word and turning to
somebody you see when he was translating
himself into german
another the facet of the man's character
you see he was being helped out
well as soon as he as
they were then the photographers all
came in the movie people they were all
well
there was no tv but i mean there's there
was newsreel all they all came in to
make
to record this great event of of his
recovery from his stroke you know
and so all his all the big shots of the
commentary
were hustling him into this big room
where we were all to be lined up and he
was to be seated in the middle and the
common turn and the you know the big
shots the police bureau not the pilot
please the police bureau on both sides
of him etc
uh well we tried to interview him what
you might call on the run in this push
and someone start out by saying you
speak english
what a question to ask a great man and
he said i speak him
the english language that's a very good
that was his answer which was all right
and then
uh somebody did ask an intelligent
question you know on the about being
pushed and then someone said
uh well i
maybe you
i don't know
without asking him he turned to sort of
looked at us and said
why do you americans
uh
make such a terrific campaign against
bolshevism
he says after all what is bolshevism
bolshevism is an interpretation
of marx
it is the interpretation of marxian
socialism originated by an american
they and we said who who and he said
well his name was daniel de leon
and suddenly a great light burst
on me
i thought my father
whose first political activity was when
at the age of 25 when he was a volunteer
worker for henry george when they
organized a single tax party because
henry george
originated the idea of a single tax
attacks on gains attacks on property
gains and gains you could do away with
all other taxes
it could even be tried today i think in
work and it was never been tried in all
history
among the people
who were volunteer workers there was a
father mcglynn
who organized or helped the knights of
labor a catholic labor organization and
he was excommunicated for his part in
this
single tax thing louis post who
afterwards became a member of the
cabinet of some u.s president and
daniel de leon
who afterwards founded
the
um the
socialist workers party of america which
still exists they run a paper called the
weekly people they're still a minor
branch of socialism they still consider
themselves the purest expounders of
marxian socialism now they do
whether or not well anyway so suddenly
lenny talking to me brought and i i
suddenly thought of my father and the
man whom he knew my father worked with
named daniel the leo
and this and this was about the whole
extent of the interview george while
with the tribute chicago tribune you uh
also went to italy and
covered in saline the rise of fascism
well
you understand that
mussolini
up to 22
was a journalist
now
actually
when i first met him in 1919
uh that was before
fascism was really a power or an
organized power and he was the editor of
the uh
well in fact the first time i met him
was at the um in 1919
that's right that's when i first met him
i was sent
to cover a a strike
in the
in turin
the fiat works and so forth and in other
parts
and i remember very well
we all arrived there we heard terrible
stories
about the working people going on strike
and yelling viva la mean and arming
themselves and the wives of the strikers
burning mr fiat alive in this furnace
and all like that well of course uh
as a reporter as i could write this up
but what was the hearst man to do who
was sent to get pictures
so he went out and he bought all the old
guns and sabres he could find in town
and he hired a lot of people
and he put him back of a wall and he
himself wrote viva la nina and a sickle
and hammer
on it and then photographed
the striking workers you see
embracing communism in russia you see
well
then of course there was the case of
senior fiat
you see who was burnt alive so the first
thing i said when i got to the hotel i
said
something about
and the man said my dear sarah i'm sorry
but
you seem to have made a mistake uh fiat
is not the name of a man
fiat stands for
fabrici
italiano
automobilique
f-i-a-t it's the automobile works of the
city of the fiat of the city of terrain
now the owner's name agnelli agnelli he
still is and nelly is one of the
biggest men in italy even today
you see he says i can call him up for
you if you want to interview him so
here's the story of the workman's wives
who were even more vicious than the
working people who
just yelled viva la nina the workers
wives who burned mr
in this but
well when there was no story
um
i was there with the i was working with
lincoln there of the world with the
world and the um the chicago tribune we
figured we're not rivals exactly so we
cooperated frequently so he said let's
go call on mussolini he's a fellow
journalist in fact he was there covering
parts of it so we went over to milan and
we called on him and
that's when he made something a terrific
declaration
he was in favor of a general strike and
he was in favor he he thought it was a
little too mild or anything like that
you see at that time he wasn't quite he
wasn't really a fascist yet he was just
the beginning of the thing you see
and he he made the phrase which
uh i
had it correctly written for me
somewhere else later he said
the
italy has need of a bloodbath
in other words he thought that violence
in the streets
labor the unions and clashing with the
police would be a good thing to spill
blood
because
he thought it would start the uh
the anti-government movement of course
that was his purpose in it
and of course later when he organized
the black shirts that's exactly what
they did they had splashes in the
streets and they spilled blood wherever
they could
and eventually
since he was the most powerful of all
the outfits the king gave him the uh
well anyway we went to see him and he
made that statement that italy needs a
bloodbath
and he talked to us as
as
carol kalego meaning my dear khalid he
called us his colleagues and all that i
mean this was long before
uh he was
you know fascism was actually started
you know by danuccio and also in 1919
the same year
earlier in the year and
when he took field me he had the black
shirts
the dalmatian legion which later became
the rdt of mussolini
he also collected all the money you know
he
uh they sent word to all the american
italians to support the nuncio's capture
and make fumey a an italian instead of a
yugoslav city send the money to my
deputy in milan benito mussolini the
editor of carrera delicera our editor of
the popular italian pardon me
and so 50 000 was raised by the
americans which mussolini stole and i
say stone because he was tried for theft
by the
association of the journalists of
lombardia at
the biggest association of the press in
north italy they tried him and and the
the verdict was that
that he took the money but he said i
used it for ours for our
general purpose i organized the fascisti
with her
well anyway this is uh this is my friend
mussolini who continued to call me
carol kalego on every occasion that i
met him
in italy before he took office
and a
very interesting point i don't know if
any people
in october 1922 is when
as when he arrived by train you see the
famous march on rome there's another
great myth of history
no fascist march on roman occupied rome
they came by pullman he came by pullman
car and the rest came in
in cattle cars or ordinary passenger
cars from the land and they got there
and the king handed over the government
to them that's all three days later he
led a march a triumphal march through
the city
himself de bono grande and all the big
people you see which is called the
glorious march on rome
of course i can tell you i have a
there's a secret one of my books
which i call i think it's an illustrator
book called i think it's called world
panorama
i tell the story that this glorious
march on rome was a fraud and all the
photographs were taken three days later
and i didn't supply the pictures but
little brown bought a bunch of pictures
to illustrate my book with and one of
them was marked the glorious march of
rome the famous picture which i call a
fraud
only they don't
identify it as that
well in 1924
in june
mussolini had his
chief competitor
the the head of the socialist party
joe giocomo
matiotti
he had him
assassinated he was stabbed 20 or 30
times
and died in an automobile
mussolini afterwards announced that he
died of a
tuberculosis hemorrhage
the people who killed him
including rossi who was or anyway
phillippelli and rossi were two of
members of the cabinet who made
confessions the actual man who stabbed
him was named dominique
i can't remember his first name albert
or something dominique was from an
american born in saint louis of italian
parents
married
either married to a miss williams or the
son of an american woman named williams
or something and dominique was the
actual assassin but it doesn't matter
rossi and phillippelli who were members
of the cabinet took the bloodstained
garments of
mattyoti and send it to mussolini to
prove
that they had done the job that he told
them to do
and
this man mussolini actually when mrs
mathioti came said where is my husband
he said i we will find him for you he he
may have gone away to france maybe he
got scared or something like that after
he knew that he that he
that they
i don't know what they did with the body
i don't know if the body's ever
what's the story behind your expulsion
from italy was it because you exposed
this thing
look on june 29 1924
i was in italy see
i built an office there not far from the
palazzo kishi where the famous balcony
that he addressed the crowds from i
could oh i overlooked that i could take
pictures of him he later said that i put
it that purposely says that one day i'd
come with a gun and shoot him that's
what they told people that didn't press
after him anyway
um
where was i uh why were you expelled yes
so i this is the day in which on the
february 29th i'll never forget the date
because he said look i forgot it was
leap year i have no i have no
appointments
i kept asking him said i'll talk to you
for hours i have nothing to do today and
he talked to me for a couple hours
nothing on politics so we discussed
art and literature and poetry and music
and all like that
and i noticed
that the
this clever man this
who'd
become the head of
of a country he figured out well who was
there just a reporter you know so he
would use praises from machiavelli and
nietzsche and all like that as his own
thinking well i'll put that over on him
he said as far as my sex life goes my
motto has always been thou goes to woman
do not forget thy will
direct out of nature you know
i mean
it's a quote only nietzsche has someone
say it not not that it was his own view
but it's from dusberg zarathustra and
things like that and then he um
he would use titles of the
books by people as if they were part of
his vocabulary
like well i am human all too human
that's another one of nietzsche's books
you know
things like that and well it so happened
that
i don't know i came across them when i
was a boy in the library and that's one
of the things that
that i
found by being able to go to the stacks
and knew all about
well
shortly after i got this interview
it was it was a well he
i would say it was probably the best
interview i ever had with anybody
because it didn't discuss politics or
daily news it was a civilized interview
you might say and they impressed me very
well his favorite sports were uh
were violating the law i mean by were
by speedy speeding through the streets
you see that was his favorite sport was
was uh
auto autowing you see
you know he killed he killed a boy once
and cornelius vanderbilt
a journalist who claims he was
mussolini's guest that day
said that mussolini as they killed the
boy and drove on at full speed he's he
said
what is one life more in the affairs of
state vanderbilt and drove on now that
is that is his story i i don't know that
mussolini was ever as crude as that
but anyway
all this time the people were going
around
with photostats there were no xeroxes in
those days
of the confessions of these people
as to the actual killing who the act did
the actual stabbing what mussolini's
orders were the part rossi and
philippelli played in it and all like
that rossi made a confession philippelli
made a confession dumani i don't know
what happened he disappeared the actual
murderer
well
like every
i had a good man working for me his name
was champhara the father of the
man who went on the andrea dora remember
the new york times man
named the
i forget that camilo i don't know if
camilo
chanfara was the son of the father but
anyway
the senior one and he he brought these
documents into me and he said look
you'll be expelled you may even be
attacked by the fascistian given castor
oil and die three months later the most
horrible death if they pour a pint of
castor oil into you they can't you can't
say they killed me you can live three
months of the most painful and horrible
pains you've ever had and there's no
solution apparently that's how they
killed people they're fascistic
so
i said well it's my job to
send the news out
and mother well of the chicago daily
news warned me he said i've had these
for months
and my office knows it and they don't
want me they want to keep me here
the associated press was run by
salvatore cartesi
the new york times man was arnold
cortesey and the london daily mail was a
miss cortese and these three people who
were not car carrying fascists but were
more fascist than anybody else except
perhaps mussolini himself
were sending the news to the biggest
paper in america the biggest paper in
england
and the associated press the greatest
news agency in the world
and so
crooked was these were these cartesians
that two of their employees
one of them was
became well-known writer that percy
winter and i
the other one
thomas b morgan or some anyway
they would come to the office frequently
after cortezi went home
and cabled the news he had suppressed
which was not favorable to miscellaneous
fascism in order to save the ap from
being scooped or from being shown up as
crooked
that's what they did right along and
they said well look we can't we can't
use the
mussolini implication and the
assassination of uh
of matthiotti that is simply impossible
you might get killed or you'll certainly
be deported
and
i sent it by mail
just did a letter
i sent it to either london or paris and
they put it on the wire and appeared
and
i said don't use it in the paris edition
but they did
which there was no necessity for that
the chicago tribune centered all over
the united states
and it was used and it finally got out
where
months and six months after the
assassination perhaps
this was in 25
and they say took place in june 24.
well um
i got ordered to leave the country see
the press corps did one nice thing for
me
with the exception to cortez who said
we'd never take part in things like this
but all the rest led by beatrice
baskerville of the world and hire a
motherwell of the chicago daily news and
people like that they called it the
foreign office they saw dino grande
minister of foreign affairs and they
came back and said you can stay it's
okay
so i gave a dinner
and about two o'clock in the morning we
were still drinking and eating and
having a wonderful time there was a
knock on the door i had that kind of
apartment in the role i was permanent
correspondent
and there were the policemen saying pack
up your things you're leaving
and i left
and when we got to the frontier
you know passport we stopped on the
italian side that well
i
i knew what the fascists
might do you see and i certainly i heard
people
going through cars yelling don't they
sell this dolby means where is an
italian dog so
well i thought i'd gonna be in a lot of
trouble here i noticed that
you know these little compartments i had
a whole compartment you see you know and
pullman they don't have them in america
each little compartment with two benches
on this side afterwards turned into beds
you know well i'm happy to be alone in
one and the next there were four men
that sleeps four you know and two of
them were in the uniform of british
admirals
and then i found out they were all four
were admirals they were all from malta
and they were all going
to england via rome and modena into
france paris
so i walked in i said pardon me admiral
to
the guy i talked to the senior
and i said look uh i represent chicago
tribune i'm being deported and
the fascists with their clubs i hear
them and that they're advancing on us
and uh
they're looking for me and you know
they'll call me to death or give me
casserole and kill me one way or another
they said we would take care of that
well they they came in
i was sitting there but i was off the
river three in civilian clothes you
understand
and uh they kept looking around and they
said
don't they sell this
the senior editor says
get out of here we are five admirals
from malta
and you see this was the 2025
i was 30 well i was 35 i could be an
admiral 35
lower grade anyway and he threw them out
and that's what saved my life that's one
of the chances i mean i is this is this
really a chance of losing my life maybe
like going over the top and finding
nobody here was
the the fascists i don't know they would
have done something to me beating me up
or clubbed me anyway
you know well anyway so
so this is the this is my episode with
mussolini and i
never saw him again or heard of him
again
this is the first in our three-part
series on george seldes a giant of a man
who's been ignored in the united states
by the establishment media
we have with us dr jean bird who is a
professor of journalism at the
university of texas
who not only nor knows george seldis but
he's also
been the prime mover in getting george
zelda rehabilitated gene your evaluation
of george silvas well i wanted to say
that what you've just seen
is sort of living history is told by
living journalists
and a historian and a press critic
who has that rare kind of experience of
having been
where history was made
and with that rare courage of daring to
set the record straight
and correct errors by journalists and
historians
cells is a man who's not been loved he's
been ignored
by many in the teaching and practice of
journalism
perhaps largely because he's
criticized the press so much and because
teachers of journalism like myself have
not been themselves in the
forefront of
press criticism
and so often they accept what is in the
media content as they given rather than
as problematic
this man has won no pulitzer prizes no
honorary degrees
he's not been on the talk show
circuit
but thanks to actv and frank morrow
who are to be commended for this
somewhat premier presentation
on cells who has
been rediscovered
and i've had some part in that several
years ago
i helped establish first of all a
special division
of our national journalism teachers
association
to recognize and encourage this kind of
press criticism and to foster
reporting such as cells has done as a
type of research is the type of
participation as well as observation if
you will
this is a lot of this has been recorded
in 20 some books that he's as he's
written
and with this in mind i set up a special
annual award for professional excellence
of this type by journalists who both
practice and criticize their profession
i immediately began a campaign in in
1979 to make sure
that george sells was given this award i
was
encouraged a lot by curtis mcdougall a
professor of journalism at northwestern
university
who said
to me i worked with professor mcdougall
for many years that in his opinion
sells more than anyone else's living
had made critical analysis of the press
popular and important
so in 1980 at our national convention at
boston university
uh
we arranged for ourselves to have this
first
this this award
and i had the honor of presenting it to
him
he had taken a bus from nearby windsor
vermont where he lives in
somewhat
obscure
and lonely life and he came down and
accepted the award
and shared with many of us a lot of the
kinds of things that you just viewed him
say
i was very honored as i say and yet
pleasantly pleased that in
in his own words and this is what he
said uh
quote this is the first such honor i've
ever received in my life end of quote
that is public recognition
by the profession of journalism
uh
at about the same time two years ago
he was being interviewed by two other
journalism teachers
ev dennis the university of oregon and
claude john
bertrand of the university of paris and
they wrote in journalism history in 1980
and i'd like to share with
you what their perspective is in what
you call
resurrection george might object to that
word
[Laughter]
but renewed recognition i'd like to
share this with you this is what they
their conclusion uh is about this man in
journalism history
many of his press criticisms were picked
up by the once vilified and later
respected hutchins commission on freedom
of the press he predated that of course
important critics and crusaders
acknowledge their debt to him and in the
end many of his predictions have proved
to be right
his once outrageous behavior made it
easier for later critics who often made
the same points but with more persuasive
diplomacy
press criticism is still not that
popular but it does exist
as you know frank we have a newspaper
and broadcast ombudsman we have a few
journalism reviews remaining we have
reporting on the press and the news
magazines and even some press counsels
as
in this assessment dennis and bertrand
pointed out
but all of them owe something
to the legacy of george sells
who fought a more sustained battle with
greater continuity than any press critic
in our history
so i'm rather proud to have had a part
in the
the
resurrection of george sells slowly he
is being rediscovered
you might be interested in in 1980
now he was 90 then he will be 93 in this
november we sent out a lot of press
releases to scores of news media back
then
and we were right there in the middle of
boston new york area and no one showed
up
for the presentation
and to my knowledge and word from others
and word
from
mr cells the the press that still
ignored him in that instance but i must
say
that they
he was a subject of a
recent feature story in the washington
post
and he has won one of the george poke
awards since ours
and his his energy and vitality
indicate he has a lot more years i hope
to watch dog the press well let's hope
so
next week on the second section of our
georgetown special
he will tell you about what it was like
in germany both before and during
hitler's regime he met hitler he talked
to hindenburg
he also tells you about the pro-fascist
leanings of the american press and the
bribes which some of the best uh the top
people in the american press took and
then suddenly started having pro-nazi
articles and pictures in their
newspapers
he will also tell us about the spanish
civil war what it was like and
particularly how the press covered it as
he said the press covered itself in
filth during the spanish civil war so
we're looking forward to that next week
the second section of our three-part
series on george zelda
good night
europe was in the hands of dictators the
thing to do is get an interview with the
dictator see
well
i was berlin correspondent of the
chicago tribune and yet
despite the fact i've been i i mean i
went to to italy and saw mussolini i
went to i even saw lenny but here i am
10 years in germany and i can't say i
even met hitler
and pierre that is looks at me says
you're crazy we spent a whole night with
hitler a whole evening with hitler
and a contract was drawn up by which the
hearst news service
was sold
to the
german papers for four hundred thousand
dollars a year within
a month or two
after this contract was made
you will find
and i have photo stats of it
gearing
and
gables
and people like that having full pages
favoring nazism appearing in the hearst
sunday supplement magazines
we can't talk of the spanish civil war
there was no civil war in spain
there was an officer's uprising i got
there as soon as possible in 36.
the second in our series about america's
premier and suppressed press muckraker
george zeldis tonight on alternative
views
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
daddy george zelda is a man who's lived
in the shadows of american journalism a
giant living in the shadows of american
journalism
why haven't you heard of him
well for most of his journalistic career
he's been
you might call it a marked man
boycotted blacklisted by the american
press establishment why
well he went after the press itself he
was the press's critic
george you've uh covered the noted and
notorious let's let's let me take off a
few names for you
uh you met leonard
i with the tribute chicago tribune you
uh also went to italy and
covered mussolini the rise of fascism
another fascist was uh adolf hitler
you met him tell us some of his uh
let's give you us your impressions of
out of here
all the dictators
i mean i think i mean i uh well i never
knew franco that was after time when as
a chicago tribune man and europe was in
the hands of dictators the thing to do
is get an interview with the dictator
see
well
i was berlin correspondent of the
chicago tribune technically well i was i
was officially
there for
say five years and then i was made
roving correspondent for eastern europe
with headquarters in berlin for five
more years in other words for 10 years i
was headquarters in berlin i had a
beautiful suite of room hotel adlon and
all that
and
i quit in 1929 when my
order from my first book was i had a
book published and all that and some
years
even after i'd quit we were i was
sitting with a lot of newspaper people
reminiscing about we were all had seen
service in berlin and there was a man
named pierre loving of the hearst
service he was then washington in the
washington bureau of the hearst service
and i said isn't it strange pierre i've
seen
hitler a dozen times i heard i went to
nuremberg to the great festival you know
that this uh what's her name this
yes that she
reasons
and lenny
she uh choreographed it was terrific it
was tremendous it was he was wonderful
you might say as a demagogue in those
things i said and yet
despite the fact i've been i've i mean i
went to to italy and saw mussolini i
went to i even saw lenny but here i am
10 years in germany and i can't say i
even met hitler and pierre that is looks
at me says you're crazy we spent a whole
night with hitler a whole evening with
hitler and i said ah
i don't remember anything
he said well he said do you remember
when the baron found
well whatever his name was the u.s and
the german ambassador united states
baron found something
gave a party
in the vilhel strasse in the foreign
office
for the leaders of the different parties
you know communist socialist
monarchists
all of them were there various leaders
and the journalists of all countries
were a couple hundred people there there
were about a hundred members of the
uh
the foreign press club the foreign
ouslandischer journalist berlin we were
all there
he says don't you remember that
everybody was nice and cordial you
talked to the different party leaders
but there was one sullen man sitting
sort of all by himself the man with the
tiny must oh my i said
all he says good talk couldn't talk when
we came in then we held out our hand and
he sort of gave you a limp little hands
i couldn't talk and you went away and
that is all the man did and no i mean i
say he was so unnoticed that i was
taking i would say to my great regret
although seeing him in action when he
became this great leader and fascinated
or
whatever he did to millions of people
you know
and yet when he was this nobody
that's exactly what he was in 19
uh when was this about 25 and 23
he had led the beer hall revolution
and
uh i have a i even have a poster or at
least somewhere i don't know uh um you
know in which it said uh
nationalists anti-semites this is that
says
uh for nine uh meeting in nine
nine uh
brow house you know the each brewery had
uh you might say a cafe where they
dispensed their own beer it was a beer
hall but you know holding a thousand two
thousand people you don't know what
munich beer halls are like they're
tremendous it's the whole the whole
nightlife was i mean
centered around them and everybody went
well he he and about i forget nobody had
300
members or something
they they decided to to start the the
nazi revolution there that they what
they call the national socialist workers
party they call the national social by
the way that's what nazi means
and it's nazism not nazism i hate that
word
nazi means national workers national
social workers party
ism has ended on when you can't cut off
one of the things
say well anyway
so he walked in with his people jumped
on a table fired bullets into the
ceiling and says the revolution has
begun they all start to laugh
and
no if the germans had a greater sense of
humor that had been no hitler but so
afterwards he went off into the street
and he and ludendorff and his 300 or 3
000 followers started marching on the
city hall to to start the revolution and
the city of munich sent out what they
called the greener the green now the
police force wore green uniforms so they
were known as the greens sent out the
green police force the police force came
saw them advancing with
there was
uh
hitler mussolini
hitler uh ludendorff leading see then
the followers
they took their rifles pointed them in
the air and fired a volley into the air
immediately
hitler fell on the ground or or loonder
fell on the ground dragging hitler with
him anyway hitler dragged himself around
the corner of a building so that they
couldn't shoot him see he thought they
were going to shoot
ludendorff got up and with his hands
raised
sought to surrender the
commander-in-chief of the nets of the
german armies during the first world war
sought to surrender to a policeman can
you believe it
well that's what happened well
uh hitler and hess
and uh
there was a trial you know
and they were found guilty of stamping a
revolt treason or something and they
were sentenced to a couple of years in
prison something like that and that
there is where i think hess
wrote minecomp but not hitler it is said
that hitler dictated the book and has
wrote it
actually it's some brilliant lines in it
some
intelligent stuff from the their
viewpoint of of the
manipulating human blind brainwashing
manipulating human beings is in that
book and i think it's cesar's idea hess
was a brilliant man
well they spent see this was the end of
23 this happened so 24 and then he came
out and he was sullen and morose and
talked to nobody and we
got nowhere and hadn't started the
movement yet i think it took quite a
number of years before it got started
how long did you stay in germany i
stayed there till the january the first
1929. so you actually though were there
to see the rise of nazism were you there
yeah uh at the time of the
of the
subsidy and promotion of
fascism by the german well that was the
secret
who knows
you see look i lived in the hotel outlaw
the richest man in germany one of the
richest men in the world also had a
suite of rooms in that hotel his name
was hugo stimus
i mean
getty
this fellow bunker who tried to corner i
mean he wasn't that type he was worth
billions of dollars now
i wrote this for the chicago tribune on
one of my trips home
but
this is the kind of story that often
everyone in the world ought to know it
who destroyed the german republic
my when i say that this man stinus the
richest man he i think he had 600 000
workers in the steel and coal plants
he also had an interest or owned 63
newspapers
he had a part interest in some of the
four big banks they were known as the d
banks you know the dresden their bank
the something there were four big banks
they were known the d banks
he had an interest in that he uh
how did he destroy germany
right
i wrote this and tribune published it
nobody knows it
except in chicago a few people perhaps
he paid his workmen once every two weeks
he sold everything he stopped selling
his stuff
for marx in germany he sold his coal his
iron his product oh he was one of the
originators of what you might call a
vertical trust
a vertical trust is not to get
everything in your line but one of each
if it helps you for instance if you've
got coal why not own a railroad
why not have a smelter why not have this
that or the other why not have an
electric plant you see
one of each you see since he had coal
and steel and everything he owned
railroad then of course he owned
newspapers for publicity and just for
his name
very well
he
took his coal and iron and everything he
manufactured and sold them abroad
england
for pounds
france for france uh holland
you see
and most of the money
almost all of it was good money i mean
hard money what they called in europe in
those days
i don't think there was any inflated
money there may be a little inflation
france may have gone
instead of five to
10 franchise maybe even 20 to the dollar
but not millions billions
in germany the price could change
say from a hundred thousand marks of the
dollar in the morning to two hundred
thousand marks of the dollar in the
evening
i mean the bank rate could have changed
to that
i have a list somewheres of how it went
from four
from four million to 4 quintillion in
the year 1923.
well he kept all his money and pounds
and shillings and marx and croner and
whatever it was pesos positives abroad
and when it came to paying his workman
he would draw a check
for a
say a thousand pounds instead of twenty
thousand pounds or a hundred thousand
pounds
get the number of marks trillions of
marks and pay his workmen and marks in
the workplace would have to as they say
take a
baby carriage load of marks to buy a
loaf of bread
now that is he ruined his own country
because when hitler came into power it
was on the slogan we didn't lose the war
we were stabbed in the back
the uh the profiteers and the so forth
and the people who ruined the inflation
people the international bankers the
jews the communists the socialist status
in the back i mean that was the big
propaganda you see
and uh it worked
and no one has ever told the truth about
people this isn't there this wrote a
book called i paid hitler the only man
ever told the truth of the crowd now
thiessen was almost
thiessen and the crooks these are the
kind of people i'm talking about stennis
is the unknown man who was on the same
rank if not higher than fiesta and
crouppen those days
he was the big newcomer
in in industry
i mean those things do happen you don't
have to be of a you know the old uh
the old vanderbilts or something like
that
he was a newcomer but he he got it all
he was the richest man as i say in
germany there was a certain period there
when after
several years in which nazism see the
party the nazi party was getting bigger
and bigger and bigger there was a
general election
in which
they didn't collapse but they suddenly
fell and the socialists took
a big leap forward
i don't know which part 1932 yeah the
reichstag election yes that's it now i
think this is the time when this and the
rest must have had their meetings
which
i think is the brown book of that season
there's a book which tells about these
meeting of who the bankers were you know
the schroeder banks and the uh and
thiessen and all the rest
now
stennis also secretly was a big
uh supplier of money
for the hitler rides so you see you see
national socialism not the nazi movement
as a reaction to
militants in the part of the working
class and the success in the electoral
elections by the socialists well
as at least the explanation
i mean
obviously i mean look after all uh
ebert had
taken a country that had been defeated
imaginably defeated in the first world
war but
it was it was a tragic defeat you know
that the french took every good railroad
train and locomotive away and things
like that
i mean germany was stripped there and
in in a few years from
under abr you know what when i met
hindenburg in which he i said what are
you doing now he says he says i'm a
military i take orders my orders now
come from the president hebert i shall
disband the army in according with his
rules and retired a private life i am
now in the employ of president abram
that's what he said and he meant it i
believe maybe at that time not
afterwards
well power went to his head too maybe
maybe this is a good point to sort of
make the lead you uh yeah you wrote a
book you can print that where you talked
about suppression and censorship in
foreign countries yes and yes especially
the role of the press in failing to
uncover
and reveal
the links between william randolph and
hitler
digest and rest
you might be able to elaborate on those
points
i never met hers by the way
but his chief lieutenant in europe
was
bond weekend carl von vega we played
poker thank god for von wegen
when we were getting
i was getting 50 a week salary i never
got more than 60 from the colonel
everybody else was getting 100 to 125.
that was good foreign pay those days
because the colonel figured out they all
want to live in europe have a good time
living is cheap give them european wages
the people on the paris edition itself
got 25 a week
people like shirer and she and this and
sheen and others you see some of them
who became noted writers afterwards
joel's who started transition these were
all oh henry miller who you know
profited he was the proofreader for the
tribute 25 a week they all got well
anyway
carl von wegen got 375 dollars a week
from colonel from hearst he got 100 from
the cosmopolitan 100 from the ins 100
from the
uh
her service 100 from the knickerbocker
press i don't know the different hearst
organizations i know it was 375 for this
reason we would play poker he was the
worst poker player i ever met because he
had to be in every part
so at the end he would take out one of
his checks you see so i kept noticing he
would say i owe
i owe 75 tonight so divide this among
you and take out a 75 check or take out
100 checks anybody got 25 dollars you
divide this among you see so hearst
magazine oh hurst internet hurst
magazine was called the first
international i think at that time big
magazine
bigger than custom followed in one time
well anyway
so he
he got that well in 1934
and this is the story that ambassador
dawn
well i've met ambassador dobbs i was a
friend of his son and daughter
william dodd jr and his daughter martha
i still write to martha she's living in
czechoslovakia well anyway
uh the idea was this hurst
a meeting was arranged by von weger at
one of the spas like
oh wherever not caused by that's in
czechoslovakia
you know the
bod carlsbad no carl's bothers checkers
what are the spas you see
uh hearst was there
hopstongle was there you know putzi
hamster who was the sort of press chief
for hitler
and a contract was drawn up by which the
hearst news service
was sold
to the
german papers for four hundred thousand
dollars a year
now this is
now in the libel suit afterwards with a
magazine called friday owned by a man
named gilmore the charge is made that
and no country in the world has heard
ever gotten more than
75 000 that's one but most of them are
40 and 50 000 a year for his complete
news service that the other 360 thousand
dollars
was a bribe
well
that is merely what a lawyer says
but what you can find and pictures of
this book is that
within
a month or two
after this contract was made
you will find and i have photo stats of
it
gearing
and
gables
and people like that having full pages
favoring nazism appearing in the hearst
sunday supplement magazines
you see
that's what i mean
if it wasn't a bribe what was it
because and then of course here they are
there are the pictures for you and and
then
mr hearst wrote an editorial signed it
with his own name in which he says that
hitler has revived the great spirit of
the old german people and there'll be a
great nation again and all like that in
favor of hitler
i mean
i don't say that he went on and said the
thing to do now is to massacre the jews
or invade poland and and and you see
curse wasn't alone in this the reader's
digest also yeah it's a very flattering
thing
well the readers died just i simply just
reading the reader's digest i came
across
uh
articles saying what's good
and hitler germany and things like that
which is pure you might say propaganda
and in those days there's no question
that the the reader's digest is
something i i don't know anyone else
except my newsletter in fact ever
pointed out in issue after issue the
reader's digest in its under
underhand crooked ways was one of the
leading anti-labor or publications in
america it had two or three well-known
anti-labor writers and they wrote
articles against unionism and labor
unions and all like that
this there is no question of that and
well i mean as far as hitler goes here
is the proof here is an issue of
reader's digest it says may 1938
and what is there
what have they got in the day 1930 out
hey a feature story by stephen roberts
the house that hitler built
all in favor of hitler
now
that's one of them now here is an
article by douglas reed it says what's
good in germany
this is dated september 1938 the same
issue no this is may 38 september 38th
now or later on and 39 on franco's side
in spain
on franco's side in spain a a uh
an article favoring oh i didn't notice
this it says condensed from the new york
times anyway it's by ellery sedgwick who
was the editor of the atlantic and who
was as close enough as to fascist or
nazis any american i know
so the bulk of the american press was
the anti-american press accepted the the
fascist statement that the other side
was read
do you ever have did you ever attend a
rally in nuremberg
yes oh yes could you could could you
sort of
could you just paint some of the picture
what that was like and what kind of what
kind of a speaker and what was the sort
of atmosphere of one of those rallies
it's incredible that the man who crawled
in the dust around the corner when they
fired
a valley into the air in 1923
by
1930 well i was in germany last 31 i
went back once or twice you know just
for a few weeks to see just what things
were or maybe for a chapter of the book
or something
but i don't know when i attended this
rally but i know i was in the press
section in the galleries there's no
question
that
either the man had it hidden in him or
the
the hysteria of the
of power
drew it out of him it's hard to believe
that this
you know he was a failed babel meaning a
corporal
he was a
runner in the you know in the first
world war
it's hard to believe that in so few
years
that he would stand up you know
glorified as i mean
as an enormous figure uh
addressing a hundred thousand people and
the the ohio hitler hive hitler and the
the the the surge of emotion which
carried everybody away except the
newspaper people i might say
and
it
i don't know it could have affected him
too
i mean his own he was
made by his own power
[Applause]
george the next topic i'd like to
discuss with you is a
is a very painful one
the spanish civil war about which
albert camus wrote
it was in spain that men learned that
one can be right and yet be beaten
that force can bankrupt spirit that
there are times when courage is not its
own recompense
it is this doubtless which explains why
so many white men
the world over
regard the spanish drama
as a personal tragedy
give us your thoughts
toward the end of 36 the war began on
july 19th i believe 36 that's first of
all look
we can't talk of the spanish civil war
there was no civil war in spain
there was an officer's uprising i think
the spanish referred to these things as
a pronunciation
but they take place in south american
latin american countries about in the
old days they used to take place every
thursday and wednesday or something like
that they took i mean all well all that
happened here was
that
that
the republic
had
started in 31 and 34
the
the reactionary elements
actually won the election
whether it was a fair election or not
i'm not going to argue whether there was
ballot boxes broken or not but they and
then
franco by the way was
an officer of the republic therefore he
committed treason in this rebellion but
before that in 34 the asturian miners
had a rebellion
because of the repressive situation
there
and
mining conditions if things are bad in
pittsburgh you can imagine what they
were the asturias
so whom did whom did the
not the not the uh
the lib not the liberal republic but the
people in charge of the republic who
were gil robles and uh and these people
who actors became the leader of the
fascists
they sent a a regiment or a small army
uh under the command of a general whose
name was franco who shot down the
the the workers the historian miners
that is why
pasionaria you see who was the wife of
an asturian minor
became the communist leader this is what
made her that
it was the 1934
shooting down of the working people by
by a man who at that time technically
was still the employee of a republic
did it
well
on the franco side there were
hitler's condor legion about 50 000
people who saw service in the aviation
and 200 000 italian infantry i'll have
you noted most the fighting and of
course the moors that franco brought in
you see now who were on the loyalist
side
in in
i got there as soon as possible in 36
but they were still doing it
they
they called the working people out of
their factories and shops
and they put guns in their hands
and they said defend the city people who
had never fired a gun some of them even
later on when the american when the
international brigade was organized alva
bessie told me that that when he came
there or some of the others in six days
they were told how to use a rifle and
sent to the front in six days mind you
instead of six months or training or
something like that
largely they called on all the unions
and the working people they called on
the asturian miners and they called on
the best miners and they called on the
uh landless peasants
you see
to
join the republican a lot of them did
but i mean there were no trained troops
at all on our side there's only one man
had the courage to tell the truth and
that was claude bowers he was our
american ambassador
and he said so and he wrote a book my
mission to madrid
in which he says so probably on this
first page it was not a civil war
it was a it was a general's uprising
against the people and on the other side
there were nothing but the people now
among the people the working people
well there were all kinds there was true
a lot of people a lot of
well
a lot is made of the fact there were a
lot of anarchists now the truth is that
there were
almost no communists
say 15 20 000
there were a larger number of socialists
but a very small fraction of the people
on the other hand the fai which was the
federacion iberica anartista the
anarchist federation of workers
in barcelona practically they were
called themselves i don't know how much
anarchists they were or whose followers
they were
but
they were an organization that i know
they ran the streetcars of barcelona
even during the war they were anarchists
you see now
as far the anarchists did not hesitate
to burn the churches i will say that
but on the other hand the republic is
accused of burning the churches and as
far as i know the republicans didn't
burn any church
i don't think the communists even burned
churches certainly the socialists didn't
burn any churches
certainly the common working people
didn't burn their own churches those
were stories that were circulated during
the war about atrocities and the part of
the republican atrocities and the people
who thought they were being fair said
well there were atrocities on both sides
i mean people who equate
you see
massacres on one side and 20 people
taken out and court martial they're shot
on the other i mean look i think that
the the franco people at least in the
books now published in spain
historical books uh
not written by radicals or reds or
anything but the history it says that in
the first 10 years of this of franco's
rule
there were several hundred thousand
people
in jail in fact everybody
who had a blue mark here and those are
mostly working people didn't know how to
handle a rifle and they'd get kicked
back
you see
they were put in jail and franco
executed at least 10 000 people a year
for 10 years after the first 10 years
after the war was over
this is not listed as an atrocity no one
ever mentions it or anything why i don't
know why
but the fact that the anarchists
destroyed some churches bauer said i
looked at them all
and i knew that they were the
these black by the way black and red
were their colors
and they didn't hesitate i mean the
anarchists would like you know nowadays
they say there's a certain atrocity it
takes place or terrorism and so-and-so
takes credit for it well in the old days
as a rule everybody kept quiet about
things like that but
not the anarchists the anarchists
admitted it
they believed in a certain amount of
terrorism perhaps
incidentally the anarchist movement
now under the new republic and that's
one of the things passionaria told me
about
it's uh in fact she got rather excited
about it when she told me she says and
the one the important things of today is
that the
anarchist movement has fallen vertically
and she sort of got up like this and
with her hand you know
which i thought was a very good gesture
well anyway this this is this is it was
foreign troops
fascists nazis
against the working people and their
allies including anarchists if you want
to say so who were
just that the other i don't know my
father used to be called a philosophical
anarchist or something just because he
didn't belong to one of the regular
parties
and i had a sympathy for prince
christian and tolstoy and prince kaputu
were anarchists i mean they were
philosophers
who financed frankl
last year i think it was or six months
ago there was a series of articles in
the new yorker
of one
of the duke of alba and juan marsh
mostly about juan marsh
the people who financed franco
why did they finance franco
marsh was
one of the biggest bankers he was used
to be a cigarette smuggler he used to
smuggle british cigarettes from
gibraltar into spain
and he was in jail once then he became a
banker then he became the biggest banker
in spain
the duke of alba was the illegitimate
son of
king james of england
he is the duke of berwick of england
he's a fitch james fitz meaning
yes
well
he used to say
i can walk
from irun on the french border to cadiz
us naval base the south of the
mediterranean without taking my foot my
feet off my own lands
that man owned millions of acres of land
he was a feudal landowner the working
people especially the farm workers had
nothing they were they were absolutely
no better than the serfs were
in russia
and that is the situation that the
republic tried to remedy it is true that
being a liberal republican not being a
radical republic they didn't take
radical measures they went slowly
gradualism
well i mean you know there are many
people with
great ideas great socialists i mean the
webs i think sydney and beatrice webb
and england the whole fabian socialist
movement of england believed in
gradualism didn't they more or less
well didn't it was too late in spain i
mean desperate
desperate diseases need this
required desperate remedies
and
they should have taken the land
immediately they did that's why the duke
of alba financed frankel because they
did take a large part of his millions of
acres of land
and uh juan marx was simply the banker
who's and this he was exposed in a
series imagine this year or last year in
the new yorker juan march the secret of
the financing of franco appeared this
year or within a year in the new yorker
but it did not appear in the new york
times at the time of the war you know
what was what was the role of the
american press story the american press
covered itself with filth almost almost
all from the first day of the war to the
other
it was incredible they the red
the red
banner was pinned on the republic
and that ruined the republic
the
all the nations got together and passed
the neutrality pact
that no foreigners would be allowed and
all the nations knew what was happening
and nobody took anything only two
nations did anything at all
for the
republic and that was mexico which tried
to send chips with food and medicines
which the united states government
prohibited
they stopped the mexicans
so
stalin did send perhaps a total some
people say 500 i mean
thomas you thomas read the books on the
war maybe 700. they had a few aviators
a few squadrons of aviators
i don't know how many there's 700 500 or
say 700 and it included doctors that
they sent it also included i might say a
lot of police officers
and i i mean the fact that stalin
helped them doesn't mean that stalin
eventually didn't betray them and
double-crossed them and all that because
he's only looking after one thing and
that was himself and his regime and he
sold the mouth you see to
to to save the
hitler for marching against russia that
was what the 1931 pact was about he
absolutely sold out the
spain so spain had no friends
now it is true that the day that bowers
came back from spain
as he walked into fdr's
office before he even got to roosevelt's
desk
roosevelt yelled to him across the big
room
bowers i think we were on the wrong side
i think i made a mistake it's a bauer's
book
that he admitted it before he even got
to discuss the matter with him but on
the other hand what did mr bowers do
what did fdr do with bowers
bauer's a poor man he sent him his
ambassador to different places so he
couldn't write his memoirs till 10 or 15
years afterwards
now bowers if someone would have grabbed
him at that time if there was some kind
of an association with a little money
and say look you deliver serious here's
25 000 we want you to deliver 25
speeches in 25 cities and stir up the
american people
when he came back with the news it might
have helped but nothing like that was
done
take the case of the the press i told
you that the press was disgraceful
uh i happened to know and when i came
back i came back at the i was there 36
37 came back into
i
37.
to annoy colonel riley r-a-i-l-e-y-h-h
who happened to be the closest friend of
adolf
uh uh uh
a h salzburger arthur hayes salzburger
who had married
cox's daughter and was owner or editor
editor owner or main owner of the times
and we were talking as
about this and i was telling him about
what was happening in spain he said look
he said i want you to talk to salzburger
so he took me
what
lotus club would that be about one of
the biggest clubs in new york city one
of the real swanky places one of the
best for the you know
took me to the lotus club to dinner with
that is salzburger took and
he listened and listened listen to me
and he said well you know i said i'm not
a journalist i'm a silk merchant
said mr salzburger he said i have given
orders i want both sides covered
equally
you see
and then when you took up the paper you
would find
the news from spain with a headline on
one side there would be a story
with the name of
carney william carney with the frankfurt
troops on the other side
herbert
l matthews with the loyal side now
let me give you an actual episode of
what happened
on one side
carney wrote a story saying the argonda
bridge was captured by franco today this
is the last
avenue that the loyalists have that
madrid has of getting food supplies
medicines and ammunitions
and the sphere meaning it's the end of
the war
on the next side there is this
eyewitness account mr matthews i went
with him
at the risk of his life because there
were shooting in the neighborhood that's
true we went to the arganda bridge and
just to say
that the story is not true we crossed
the bridge to the other side the trucks
were coming in from barcelona it's true
that they were close by we could hear
machine gun fire that's close
but the avenue was open
you see it all like that now mr ox
mr salzburger not being an editor his
idea of fairness was to have a story
saying the arganda bridge see and an
eyewitness account saying it ain't so
balancing each other that gives a fair
play to both you can't equate a total
falsehood with an eyewitness account of
a truthful revenge can you but that's
he's he told the people now it is true
that uh who was it uh
talesie who wrote this book the power
and the italy's
gate elise that's right
he wrote this book in which it's the
first time although you knew it
these were known as the fascist phalanx
in the bullpen
there were four assistant or five
assistant editors mccall was one of them
uh
two
e.l james
and they were
well i'm not going to bring any
religious men i don't want to
have any religious disputes about it
but they were catholic in the catholic
establishment the united
stand to be
running a christian crusade against
godless communism
that is what he was running the crusade
you see and that he was no doubt backed
by
the vatican the vatican afterwards uh
pius xii bless
the italian troops that came back you
know
well anyway this fascist phalanx he says
plainly that they were catholics who
slanted the news from their religious
viewpoint because there were 700 people
sent from russia they said there was a
russian army there now no one has ever
seen one russian soldier by soldier i do
not mean an aviator or a mechanic in the
aviation unit or a member of the tank
corps
i mean an infantryman there was not one
russian soldier infantryman there were
if not
two hundred thousand there were
troops i myself
saw rounded up
in a in a wire enclosure although there
was no reason for keeping a prisoner
they loved us
twelve hundred italians who came over to
our side when the first four divisions
ran away at the battle called
the battle of
guadalajara that's another misnomer it
was the battle of brethren
which was 10 or 15 miles they tried to
get to guadalajara they never got there
i was in guadalajara waiting for them
they never got there
at bruja they were stopped
they were stopped by whom
by the italian working people of
madrid under
a man named
carlos general carlos his real name was
victoria vidali he was the trieste boy
he went and organized all the italian
working men in madrid the day that
franco started their rebellion
and when he heard that there were
italian troops there
he went out with a megaphone
and there were four divisions at what
tried to get the guadalajara and
surround madrid and he had fratelli
italian we are your brothers what are
you fighting for
you see we're fighting for the welfare
of all the people in all this jews and
you are fighting for mussolini who said
you were being sent to ethiopia on
police duty
well it opened their eyes they didn't
even know they were in spain some of the
first ones who landed there
they were getting 40 lira's a day more
though
he did pay the law when he sent him
abroad so you say the press was and the
press
look i mean in that situation when the
italian troops ran away and we
interviewed 1200
we arrived we talked to the italians who
said we're glad that the it's over for
us
we come back
what 50 miles perhaps or whatever it was
to madrid
and there is the censor with a telegraph
addressed to matthews of the times
saying
why do you say there are italian troops
in spain carney says there aren't any
carney on the other side
where it had the italian troops set to
telegram that there were no italian
troops there and matthews who with me
were interviewing the italian prisoners
who had seen these these forty thousand
run away when when vidalia talked to
italian to them
get a telegram like this signed e.l
james
and i expose things like this and the
times gives an orders never to mention
my name or review my books because i
tell the facts about how dirty and
crooked they were in the in the spanish
war it was james's fault as i say mr
salzburger didn't even know what was
happening
i mean if anybody i ever hated in the
newspaper business
i think i hated james a whole lot more
than i would hate an out-and-out known
crook like
uh
say
william randolph first who made a deal
with hitler for four hundred thousand
dollars for his news service
this concludes the second of the
three-part series on that magnificent
man george zeldis
we have with us dr jean bird professor
of journalism at the university of texas
who knows george zelda and has had a big
part in reviving the name of george
seldis
in journalistic circles and also for the
general public
gene what is your evaluation of george
seldus and his contribution to
journalism and to history well this man
who's just come into your living rooms
and dens
is a voice of both the past and the
present
he's not only a man who is uniquely
humble and i think courageous in his
criticism of the press historically
and a critic of historians also but he's
a great and grand man who practices and
continue to practice journalism
you note he is very unpretentious and he
is refreshing
in contrast to many of the pompous
eyewitness
anchor people we see on television
he's in contrast also to the frequently
conceited and rather arrogant
reporters and self-centered professors
and
a few doctoral students
we see who blindly accept the new york
times is the word of god
and perhaps you'd agree how much more
realistic
are his observations than
you recall the old walter cronkite tv
series titled you are there
and the over dramatized docudramas that
we see
in which television makes
yesterday's news seem like ancient
history
cells is is unique as i think you would
agree after having seen in this series
because he's one of those few
journalists who thinks about what he
does
and that is an observation of
of
ever dennis who is a professor of
journalism at the university of oregon
and who wrote an article about him in
journalism history
shortly after we gave him the award in
boston in 1980 which helped to bring
cells back to the national limelight
dennis a former colleague of mine also
points out that
cells has rejected in many ways the
practices of journalism but he's never
never rejected the idea of journalism
also that he is an angry man but he is
not bitter and i think anyone seeing him
talk
on this series we will see that that
comes through
he's valuable to scholarship also
because he does research in a sense
by matching reporting with better
reporting
often as a participant and as an
observer of sorts
combined and this adds to our original
knowledge about the world and about
history
and in our own field of communications
as you may know we too often i think
rely just upon analyses of content that
is what is reported and on survey
research methods to as major research
tools to tell us about what's what go
what's going on in the world
also he's an interpreter of history as
well as historian he's somewhat of a
living paraphrase
of mark twain's
reminder of how much people know that
isn't so and perhaps uh somewhat of a
paraphrase of the rather brash remark
attributed to henry ford that all
history has bunk
or as anna cells reminded me when i
talked with him in boston
that
he
euripides for example
said let the facts speak for themselves
and he
seldom has been very influenced by
mountains advice
quote i speak the truth
not so much as i would but as much as i
dare and i dare a little bit more as i
grow older
and that gives us hope because a lot of
people including my colleagues who
thought he was dead those who knew even
about him
uh
they are
we're not that habit he's still alive
and i suspect that a lot of the people
he's criticizing the press are not that
pleased that he's still around but i and
certainly you and a lot of other people
don't share that hope
is there
there's one thing that strikes me very
very strongly and that's the fact
that this man is a cultured man he knew
what he was talking about he was
intimately familiar with the culture of
the countries he was in he knows
five at least five languages always knew
the language of the country he was in
and yet nowadays do you see that well
frequently the criticism of the press
today does not have that kind of depth
for a number of reasons perhaps and this
brings to mind the fact that he
had
an entree and a direct contact with many
incidents and many sources that perhaps
today modern public relations and modern
press agency may inhibit so he did have
that special kind of privilege and
one wonders what he's going to expose in
his in his next book or the book that
will be next
it is an expose on public relations
and so perhaps
that has to be taken into account in
contrasting him to some of the more
modern critics
uh people like dave halbert stamina this
book the powers that be now that became
a bestseller
and many of nader's investigations are
done through direct type of observation
investigation
i don't know it
sells is a unique man who's lived in a
unique time and had a unique kind of a
passage if you will in some of these
instances which he shared with us on
film i know on the networks for instance
they refused to let their reporters
learn the language
become acculturated and actually become
intimately involved and knowledgeable in
the country that they're in situation
that they're working in when they're
there very long they jerk them out and
bring a total stranger back then this is
policy which is and we can see
we can see how the reporting suffers
from it
well uh again i think that uh
many of you let's face it he's heading
for a hundred and so that the practices
of the media have changed
and he i think many of his uh
criticisms remain solid the kinds of
things he talked about in the 30s many
of these things are still true do you
think that do you think that the blatant
censorship and distortion and lying
still goes on it's not as severe as i
think that when he talked about the
press ethics in the 30s that kind of
poke fun at him but
probably there has been a general
improvement in
oppressed ethics in general but
he is still
he was warning us for example in the 30s
about the dangers of cigarettes problems
of alcohol and so forth
and yet that is very timely today he
talked about internal threats
from corporate pressures as compared
even to the outside the pressures from
the government and that's still relevant
today
so perhaps
some of the newer critics are different
some ways but in other ways they're
carrying on his tradition
we'll see this tradition more intimately
next week
in our last section of
this three-part series on george zelda
because we'll
he'll tell us about his newsletter in
fact he actually started a newsletter
which had nationwide circulation
how it was destroyed by the mccarthy era
and he himself was hauled up before the
mccarthy committee
he talks about the press distortions and
covering
revolutions going on in mexico
and once again he talks about these
things that the regular press ignored
like the cancer and cigarettes and also
the american concentration camps they
are with us and they are legal and he
exposed them first and this is something
that still hadn't talked about in the
regular media so we have another full
hour about george seldis next week on
alternative views
good night
[Music]
i wrote 10 20 articles 10 for the
mexican viewpoint to the people 10 from
the government that is 10 from the u.s
embassy viewpoint the oil interest
against the people he suppressed
the other side he suppressed the
people's side
and they were for 25 000 so i telegraph
this one thing i will say in favor of
our colonel mccormick i said these are
forgeries so he says don't buy them
three months later they appear on the
front page of the hearst press sold them
to hearst for 25 dollars
a cure fraud done by whom by four
general motors chrysler
well
at that time the press was so corrupt
you might say
i mean i'm talking of a period of 50 60
years that there was no mention of these
things
they will never forgive me the one thing
they won't forgive is a critic of the
press apparently
the last of our series of programs on
george zelda america's premier press
muckraker tonight on alternative views
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
george seldis is a man who's lived in
the shadows of american journalism a
giant living in the shadows of american
journalism
why haven't you heard of him
well for most of his journalistic career
he's been
you might call it a marked man
boycotted blacklisted by the american
press establishment why
well he went after the press itself he
was the press's critic
talking about examples of press
censorship
colonel mccormick was the
editor of the chicago tribune the
supposed owner also actually it's owned
by the medell trust which owned the new
york daily news and the chicago tribune
and liberty magazine and uh
other things well anyway
colonel mccormick sent me to mexico and
i thought well look this is a situation
seems to have two sides to it
there's a religious quarrel going on
they're the labor unions you see they're
the oil workers who are fighting the
labor union all that i will write
10 artic
or i'll take 10 subjects
oil workers the hacienda the estates uh
the religious question the shooting up
of trains the terrorists and all that i
will write that from what i know i got a
lot of my information from
ernest greening who after we became
he was a labor man
and there was somebody there from the
american federation of labor organizing
the
mexican workers
what was his pain oh he's quite a
well-known person anyway well these are
the americans i was with to get the
mexican side you see on the other hand
the ambassador was out there was arthur
lane wilson with charges the affair and
he was really one of the worst
i mean when i mentioned people like uh
this uh
uh
affable head and one of the heads
greening and the rest he says skunks
liars
they're just
reds or something like that he yelled at
me you see
and at the same time he had in his safe
these fake
russian uh
these fake documents of an american of
of a a plot
you see which um
which a man named avila who was a an
agent you see was trying to sell
us that five american senators you see
were in
in a plot to establish a communist
regime senators like
lafollette you know people like that
they had the documents and i saw them
you see we went to the embassy and just
spotted an avalanche got them out and
lane handed it to him and so
he says you see
this is from the the minister of war you
see
do you know what the first thing i saw
was it said
something ministry of petroleum
typed a ministry of education typed out
and the word ministry of war typed
across or something like that so when i
went to see greening and the rest about
it they said well of course they're
forgeries i said they were even written
in bad spanish because avila is a texan
and his spanish has learned spanish he
can't even speak decent spanish and he
himself probably wrote them
you see and they were for 25 000 so i
telegraph this one thing i will say in
favor of our colonel mccormick i said
these are forgeries so he says don't buy
them three months later they appear on
the front page of the hearst press sold
them to hearst for 25 000
well to get back to why i quit the
tribune and wrote the book
i wrote 10 20 articles 10 for the
mexican viewpoint to the people 10 from
the government view that is 10 from the
u.s embassy viewpoint the oil interests
against the people he suppressed
the other side he suppressed the
people's side see
as a as you say he's one of the most
world famous xenophobes would you tell
that story oh colonel mccormick you want
to hear a story about him again well i
will illustrate you i will illustrate
the kind of man he was
he hated
although he was the son of an ambassador
u.s ambassador to russia during the 1905
war by the way
the son of an ambassador
uh
he hated everything european
he hated i think even anything american
outside of what he called chicagoland
he was a xenophobe
that was really a provincial to the
to his own
section chicago
well
floyd gibbons was our main roving
correspondent the roving correspondent
there's only one job on every great
organization like it you can go wherever
you want you can go into anybody else's
territory you get double pay
and you're free at an expense come
nothing it's famous floyd gibbons was
the roving correspondent
and they decided to fire floyd gibbons
for certain reasons
uh he called us together at the ritz
hotel
we had dinner and then we went up to a
room and we were say 18 or car sec 15 8
whatever it is then you know one uh
berlin rome paris and so forth you know
i don't think we were maybe more than 10
because the tribute wasn't as big as the
times which may have had 50 men in
europe including assistance
anyway he said how many of you people
speak french well if we were 12 i'm sure
10 raised their hand because after all
it's the international language how many
you speak german well i was burman
correspondent so four
you see
uh how many of you speak spanish perhaps
one
and
the colonel sort of looks around and
then he points
and he says i have decided
to
name larry rue
chief roving correspondent now larry was
a bright boy and a fine boy and all like
that
he flew his own aeroplane
uh
but someone said colonel
larry is the only one who doesn't speak
any foreign languages
and the colonel says that's the man i'm
looking for i don't want my bright
american boys ruined by these goddamn
foreigners
that's what he that's what he actually
said to us you know i'll tell you a joke
about the colonel
the colonel came to paris
as i said i was in the press section of
the army so during the versailles treaty
making i went to paris to see what was
going i traveled with woodrow wilson for
three days and things like that
the colonel who was in the fifth
but i mean he was a big shot you know
after all he was
the supposed owner of the tribune
although he was the lieutenant colonel
of artillery of the fifth artillery of
the first division he came to paris and
we used to have little meetings at the
maurice hotel which was press headphones
and all like that and the word got
around
do you know what colonel mccormick asked
he said he said he thought the ukraine
was a musical instrument
this was not the making of the
versailles treaty
george there's a lot of people in the
labor movement today feel that they get
a bad deal in the press
in fact exposed a good deal of the
history of anti-labor bias why don't you
talk a little bit about that
i mean look the anti-labor bias
has always been in the newspapers no
matter what they pretend to be
i mean and every in every city as a
world that'd be one paper that perhaps
would be a little bit liberal like the
leader my paper in pittsburgh where i
started that's why i started on because
it's going to be a liberal paper there's
a labor paper labor unions did get
notices we had a labor editor you see
but
the gang
the the bosses the banks really on the
paper you see now
actually
how
how i got started with
after after the spanish war
a magazine called can got started then
one called friday this was all in which
we were all looking for somewhere to
tell the truth or the facts if you don't
like the word truth we couldn't so that
from i said how did i start my paper i
figured out there was only one way to
start
we happened to know a man who was
connected with some junior and we said
look we're going to start this paper
we're going to publish all the news
that's suppressed a large part of the
suppressed news a large part of it is
concerns labor
now
to get some we'll get you some a sample
dummy and we're going to make a low
price at 25 cents for 12 issues sample
issues and he went out to the labor
unions of new york city
and the day we started
in fact the first issue of may 1940 we
had six thousand subscribers before we
were started all were union men
now
we got eventually we
we were starting towards a million i had
a maximum 176 000
subscribers uh and i would have gotten a
million if it wasn't for the red baiting
people wrote in saying
if you can mail it in a plain envelope
so no one will know what i'm getting i'd
like to get your magazine something like
that
george take off a few of the things that
you tried to expose in your
weekly in fact that the establishment
press were
ignoring
first
look we found out that the federal trade
commission
what is and always has been a sort of
the watchdog for the health and welfare
of the american people
uh
drugs
tobacco
uh
even even car
financing
uh
the federal trade commission we found
out issues more than 365
what we generally call fraud orders a
year they issue stipulations
they issue uh
anyway they even have trials and court
decisions whatever it is you see orders
whatever it is
well
at that time the press was so corrupt
you might say
i mean i'm talking of a period of 50 60
years that there was no mention of these
things there was no nation when a a
a dollar a bottle thing to cure
consumption cure would be put on the
market and pure frauds but there were
big frauds done by whom by four general
motors chrysler you will you believe it
well look
this is a simple little matter
they have a fine each of the comp each
of the big dealer has a financing
department you can buy a three thousand
dollar car which was big money in those
days see
financing it for three years for six
percent fair enough right
this is what the fraud order says
during the year you paid 180 the first
year six percent of three thousand
dollars in the second year you have paid
off a thousand dollars you only owe two
thousand dollars but the financing
department of general motors or cit
which was ford's or the other would say
180 a second year
the third year you only owe 1 000
but you're paying 180 that's 18 interest
so it averages out to 12 percent
interest so the fraud order by the ftc
addressed the four general motors i
don't know if i have i may have it in
here a photostat of it and all the rest
says you cannot
claim six percent when you under these
circumstances it's six percent on the
balance due and not on the original
price of the car and do you know
millions of people paid it and still
thought they were paying only six
percent for financing their car another
issue you took up certainly ahead of
your time another issue you took up
certainly ahead of your time certainly
ahead of the a surgeon general's report
in 1964 was smoking what did in fact do
about smoking as i always said the three
greatest powers in this country so far
as the press are concerned
are automobiles because they're the
three biggest group advertisers
automobiles
uh tobacco
drugs and cosmetics
now you can you think of anybody
i don't know this bigger i mean oil
doesn't that well oil is uh
oil doesn't have to advertise
groceries
no i mean a lot of groceries advertised
but no this these are the three biggest
three groups
always you know they they appear in
editor and publisher it's the 50 largest
groups of advertisers and what they
spent this year hundreds of millions
each year and one two three one three
two three one two these three are always
the first three they never vary
very well my claim was and we
i think we proved it in fact that each
of these three
corrupted the press or had an influence
the press that just as
this faking of this three six percent on
the cars
that the president would never show it
up and would not print the fraud orders
when they were issued we printed them
especially when we found out we could
get one every day if i was short of a
story i'd always get a fraud order story
see
now
there were there was
tobacco came about in this way
uh
this this the tobacco story i started
before i started in fact because in 1938
dr pearl of the head biologist of johns
hopkins came out with a little pamphlet
which he sent me
it was called
tobacco smoking and longevity
in 1939
a man named ickes who was the u.s
secretary of the interior
an ex-newspaper man
and whom i knew fairly well and he
called me up or wrote to me and said
look i am having a debate
with frank gennette of the genetic chain
i think it is one of the biggest changes
in the world and today it is a rather
good chain of newspapers
showing you that the press is a better
press when the great chain like annette
does something pro bono publico you know
the general welfare very well
he's having a debate on town meeting in
the air
which meant 10 million american
listeners in 1939
on
the press and he said i he is taking
aside the press and i'm the critic of
the press now give me some episodes
to which to have
documentation on my charges so i said
well of course you know everybody knows
about the escalator that broke and three
or four people were dragged and killed
at either macy's or gimbles and no
messier gimbal story of that time
ever would get in the paper
of course in my hometown there was a
rape case where the owner of the
department store used to rape the girls
and they had to keep quiet didn't get
the papers when one girl sued it was
suppressed
the philadelphia paper
published a story and brought it into
pittsburgh a different thing
well
i said these stories are always being
suppressed you see now i happen to know
that dr pearl the head of johns hopkins
medical
addressed to him in new york state
medical association here in new york
city
and nothing appeared in the papers about
it
so in the questioning period you see
they asked for mr ickes what proof have
you and he went and he mentioned you
know an elevator breaks down or kills
somebody or a little accident in the
escalator and department store
never gets in the paper something like
that or a fraud order against some goods
that they sold never gets into the paper
those are ordered
almost every week or every day as i told
you
and then of course there's the case of
smoking and then he enlarged a bit on
this you see
and
what happened afterwards was you might
say even worse than the original
suppression
the
the new york herald tribune which had
never mentioned
dr pearl's visit to new york at all
came out with a headline saying
ekie's lies again
this was the headline then it said of
course
ickies may not be to blame because look
at the unreliable source he has
see me because by this time i had
already written
four books critical of the press and
have already had orders that i was never
to be mentioned anywhere so when they
chance to attack me they attacked me you
see
then the times did something mr james my
former colleague in the press section
the army did something
he took the 38th story you see
which i said had been suppressed
because i thought it was suppressed
i didn't remember the times and sure
enough on page 16 one day
that
this story was covered as follows
pearl didn't speak entirely about
tobacco he spoke about longevity
and he mentioned and the hard work
you see and the headline was a column
story as most of the comments in the
times hard work never hurt anybody says
dr pearl and that's what the story was
about hard work was good for people and
the way it is if a person gives up work
you know like people are retired you
know they're they're just looking toward
the grave or something i've always felt
that way about people well anyway
so
james says
we did publish it and he has marked in
the last paragraph it says
dr prayer also shows some charts of the
effect of smoking all longevity at just
one paragraph four or five lines that's
all it said
the main thing with these
he had these charts you know
these things made up on great big charts
and they frightened the life out of
everybody
what were some of the other stories you
covered in
in fact
i had one helper i did all the writing
how can you get
every day we came out with
investigative reports
with exposes
and things like that where do you get it
i say frankly
i now can tell you that i never
mentioned the name of anybody who sent
me stuff
but now that they're dead i mean i said
drew pearson gave me one of the biggest
stories of all
in the middle
of i don't know in the middle of the 19
to 19
what 40 to 50 in the middle of 1940 but
several years after the war was over we
were
they revived the idea we may have to go
to warwick russia you see
well someone had a brilliant plan of
going by the north pole
uh and training troops in
in uh
through canada
drew pearson got the story it was called
operation mustangs for the training of
special snow troops to cross to cross
over into russia which would be a
terrific surprise attack
drew was afraid he might go to jail if
he published it
so he sent it to us and we came out
operation muscats plans for war you see
and all like that that's one story
about the role of the uh of the american
legion that's probably well look you did
expo i mean of all the sacred
cows in the i mean there are certain
things which is known as uh
as the sacred cows in the press i mean
the there's some
there's some
it's known as the
sometimes known as the sob list
you know
and there are things like that and then
there's a business off bom list business
office must i'm talking about the old
days well among the sacred cows of the
press i mean there's certain things you
cannot mention any church religion
preacher rabbi priest anybody in trouble
even to this day tobacco was sacred
certain patent medicines they advertised
the department stores were sacred a lot
of things are no longer sacred the press
today i say is
a million times better than what it was
the american legion always was one of
the sacred idols of the press
i was
in
europe i just gotten a job for the
chicago tribune
but i was not in paris the american
legion was organized in paris
yes i was in paris because i think it
was before i was out of the army that
the american legion was organized in
paris in 1919.
you see i was in the army till
june 1919 i got the job back in
september october
to go back to europe the time you say
very well
the legion was organized by a bunch of
officers
including
uh
not you know it was colonel theater
roosevelt son
yes
theodore roosevelt jr whatever his
name's son done
also the president of the prudential
life insurance people like that who were
officers whatever else they were they
were the heads of corporations or
corporation lawyers or people of that
sort now what was the purpose
of founding the legion
the purpose of find a founding the
legion
was to end the unrest
which might be caused
by the soldiers returning to america
they were scared
to what
of unrest of course they put the red
label on the unrest actually they knew
that
the majority of them were working people
they would demand better conditions
they'd risk their lives they were
entitled to a better world we were they
were promised a better world to live in
the phrase was common all like that
so the idea was to form a patriotic
group you see which would hold down any
liberal or radical movement in america
that was a purpose now there were
letters
of which i had one and which i published
later on first on the stationary of
swift and company you see which
practically asks for contributions for
that purpose
and all this
and that was really what the purpose of
the legion now
nobody
knows for instance that
many years later he when the legion had
been accused of strike breaking now
uh haywood brune who founded the
newspaper guild in 33 or 34
he said the american legion is the
largest strike breaking force in america
he said that
general smedley butler of the marines
he said i've never known a a leader of
the legion who didn't sell them out
the legion had
beautiful
clubhouses and many cities all supplied
by the corporation heads of people like
that
no one knows
because it was not published in anywhere
but in the labor press
that many many
years after all the strike breaking
which the legion engaged in one of their
commanders his name was call murray
commander-in-chief of the american
legion issued an order
which
was not published in the general press
which tells the legion that and all
strike breaking in the future could not
be done anymore in legion uniform not
even not even the legion cap
which is an admission that they've been
breaking strikes up to them isn't it
when he says to stop doing it in uniform
george you mentioned the problem of red
dating and in fact finally succumbed to
the whole tide of hysteria that was
sweeping the country during the mccarthy
period
what about your own relationship with
joe mccarthy you were called before the
committee why don't you give us a sort
of relay some of that experience well
you see we went out of business in 50
and i wasn't called before the mccarthy
committee in 1953 but just for a minute
i want i i must tell you that
at the end
so
that
letter people said the letter carriers
tell us that that people are taking our
names in the post office of all
subscribers to your paper
well that was martin dye's work i think
largely because martin dies simply
listed in fact as as a
subversive organization something like
that
well in 1953
uh
two guys named conan shine
one of them is roy cornell one of the
leading attorneys in new york city
they took it upon themselves or mccarthy
sent them and they went to
they went to uh
europe and they came back with a list of
200 american authors
i think it was 200 at least 100 whose
books appear on the us i s united
states information service libraries
there
and
mccarthy took it upon himself or maybe
they gave him a list of those that they
didn't like
but anyway one after another of the
people whose books appeared were called
before the mccarthy committee
in
washington
well
i think i was the last person for the
day
i was called in
uh
how do you swear by the bible or do you
affirm i swear by the bible i put my
hand eraser and
the lawyer for the
name roy cohen says have you now or have
ever been a member of the communist
party i say never absolutely not
well
i heard well
people sort of
uh
and then
cohen says but
you're listed
as one with the dies committee would you
say the lies committee lies i say if the
dice committee says so then they lie
well that sort of offended everybody but
i didn't mind the fact that i was being
asked questions
but this lawyer
was uh well i will
maybe libelous to what i think
internally i will not say because it may
be libelous but this is what he did
after i took an oath that i've never
been a member of the communist party
which i'm willing to do it before the
supreme court
i'm a registered democrat i voted a
republican ticket for senator
aiken of vermont because he's the best
senator and all that well anyway
during the hearings
suddenly
this
attorney called but he says you forgot
to mention the name of the cell in
chicago and in connecticut which you
will remember i said what do you mean by
sell cell or something you know he said
you were a member of a group i said no i
was a member of no group i don't know
what you're talking about but you see he
tried to trap me
that i think is called entrapment or
something i mean by
asking questions like this you see
so at this point
senator simonson say well
what are your politics mr selles and i
said to him
well i live in vermont
i have a home i'm a registered
democrat in vermont but i say this is
for the primaries but at the election
time i have always voted for a friend
the man from who you used to buy flowers
from his name is george aiken has the
best nursery at putney vermont and i
bought the republican aiken and the rest
of the ticket democrat he says one of us
said simon tuna turned out to be a
democrat that sort of
knocked the the
the hearing out pretty well
well there were some more questions you
see oh yes shall i tell you about j.b
mathews question about the catholic
church well i'll tell you about that
matthews who was their investigator you
see
suddenly uh
interposes and says yes but you wrote a
book against the catholic church
well i mean technically you can write a
book about foreign church it's not
treasonable is it or
subversive anyway i said oh i said
i said mr matthews if you're referring
to the vatican yesterday today and
tomorrow
harper suggested i translate a book and
i did a translation but i threw it away
and supplied my own stuff my wife did
some of the work and
it appeared under our names and the
catholic book club took it as their
monthly choice the catholic book of the
month club book
well
that ended that you say well after a
while mccarthy says you wait outside i
have somebody else to talk to say and
i'll call you later and then the colored
man walks in
and i wait and wait and wait sitting
with the ap up washington post and other
men they weren't allowed in the meetings
you see
just you see if anybody
refused took the fifth amendment or
refused or
something like that they'd be held over
for a public hearing the next day with
the
movies the bright lights and everything
else you know they made a show of this
thing
so
i'm talking to these people
and suddenly the door opens
mccarthy symington the whole staff
cohen matthews they all walk out
and
i sort of said senator you said
oh he says
and then he says to these people
freeman and zeldas are cleared i said
well i said the senator i i you don't
probably don't realize it but
i'm here voluntarily i didn't have to
come he says it's like hell he said
you were subpoenaed i sent the fbi after
you
i said well i said the senator look at
the uh subpoena
there was a subpoena you know of the
committee or whatever it is
and where it was supposed to be signed
joe mccarthy it was blank it was the
carbon
the secretary by mistake had sent me the
carbon the original sign he
mccarthy says i'll clear this for you
and signs that joe mccarthy and hands it
to me i lost it i don't know where it is
but it's a good be a fine document maybe
it's in pennsylvania at the university
george that was uh that was 1953.
what have you been doing with yourself
for the last 25 years
writing books about the press
and getting suppressed by the press
are you bitter about that no i'm not
well i mean look i'm glad to say that
the press today
except
uncertain things i mean i still think
that
they will never forgive me the one thing
they won't forgive is a critic of the
press apparently
at least i know that from my case look
if if you were
publishing if a book is published
and if 300
leading
newspapers in the 300 well-known book
reviewers are sent copies
and not one newspaper in
boston philadelphia new york
pittsburgh chicago
mentions the book even mentions it
don't you think that it's it's more than
a uh a slip
after they have a lot of books to review
you know but i've had some best sellers
you know in the old days and yet there
was not one there were three papers
mentioned this review out of 300
leading papers the houston chronicle
the san francisco chronicle
and the hawaii what the leading paper of
honolulu the times union or the union
news or whatever it is the leading paper
hawaii and this is what they did they
attacked me
it wasn't a favorable review it was an
attack now if you got the book there
anywhere
in this book
even the gods cannot change history my
whole idea is to say that history is
reported wrong and this is a correction
from personal experience
one of the chapters there says
the versailles treaty
was
and the league of nations was all ruined
because the chicago tribune got an
advanced copy
and the man named fraser hunt
gets all the credit from
taking the the copy and risking being
arrested or something after all we were
still the piece that i don't think had
been signed
you see i know now where we got it from
i only found out a few years ago we got
it from eugene chen the chinese delegate
anyway
there were 30 copies of the treaty this
was one of them of the 30 leading
nations each had only one copy and the
chinese delegate slipped it to us
well it was spearman lewis my whole
point is spearman lewis did the greatest
it's called the greatest scoop in the
history of the world that's what that
was called the times the chicago tribune
they ran four solid pages of the text of
the treaty
you know of any other story had four
solid pages of type
i don't know of nothing i know of
nothing not even the armistice the end
of the war
i mean different stories yes but one
item and this was used to raise
opposition to the treaty this was used
to raise our position look so my whole
point is spearman lewis is i want to
give him his honor and fraser hunt
happened to be going home and carried it
in his suitcase it was spearman hunt was
the editor of the paris edition the
tribule at that time
and 1919 you see and this was his great
story
so
the
so
when i read this attack on me in this
hawaiian paper this honolulu paper
i noticed that the man said
he does however give credit where
creditors do he credits
uh fraser hunt with bringing the treaty
to america in other words the guy had
opened it up and read one paragraph and
hadn't read the story that fraser hunt
is getting the credit and deserves
nothing it was spearman lewis's treaty
so he missed the whole point so i wrote
to the editor see so the editor
had a column you see in which i say of
course your reviewer didn't read the
book and it's took note notorious that
reviewers do not read books they cannot
read books they haven't got time to read
the books to review
and this man has
done this so they ran my letter but they
ran a reply from him
saying nevertheless you see
some attack on me of some sort
as a person who spent a lifetime
more than 70 years now as a
vocal and persistent critic of the press
have you seen much progress over that 70
years
so i mean when i say the press is very
today i mean you think the the people
who suppress things the advertisers and
automobiles
tobacco
patent medicines
today medicines are discussed broad
orders and stuff
that automobiles are discussed
uh and certainly tobacco is still that's
not quite a sacred cow but it's still
being discussed
i mean there's still something appears
in the paper when something is done like
when the government issues a report
it may not appear on the front page
where it should appear
but it does appear
so as a person who curses the darkness
for so many years you see some light now
well i mean there's no question the
picture of that right now
you know frank that's a remarkable man
we've just seen
in an era when
the press themselves have been become
celebrities
he's really uh
an unknown giant of american journalism
oh that's true i
i have such strange feelings about
about this program and him because as
you know i've been doing
research into press criticism and the
american power structure for several
years now
seven or eight years
and although the name george seldes was
not unfamiliar it was just a name i i
didn't have any idea that this man was
such a giant such a neglected giant and
reading these back issues and in fact
there's a goldmine of information there
that
i'm i'm just staggered by it well it's
it's a poignant commentary and i only
ran across him by
by accident frank i was about five or
six years ago
doing some research on how
working people and specifically unions
have been treated in the press and i ran
across his name
and about a year and a half ago i i
called him up
in vermont never really expecting that
i'd even find him
and i called up and said
hello
george seldis and he says yes
i said is this the george and he
interrupted me and said yes i'm still
alive
[Laughter]
well he's still alive we could see that
by the uh
just the vibrancy of the man it really
kind of he just exudes warmth and
vitality he's 90 years old now but you'd
really never know it as i'm sure the
viewers can tell from just the tape what
amazes me is that he's still working
he's in there clipping making clippings
and everything still is he still riding
what's his life like well he's still
writing yeah he's in i guess
semi-retirement although he really
objects to the word retirement he just
sees that as
you know is akin to you know death
he's uh he's a worker he's he he spends
he all he spent about 45 years in
vermont
and now
vermont winters are a little tough for
him so he
spends the winter down at his cousin's
place and out on long island watermill
new york
where that's where the interview took
place
it was a year ago
last april
what about his background how did he
grow up what was his parents like
well
his uh
is interesting is he was born in 1890
and uh his father
was a
self-self-proclaimed philosophical
anarchist he read the works of people
like kropotkin
and tolstoy and seldis himself grew up
on a utopian communal farm
and he recalls that the air was thick
with political debate
and he remembers
people like emma goldman traveling
through and maxim gorky and all other
names from the
from rus from the russian revolution
the boarded revolution of 1905.
seldous himself
wanted always to be an artist and it's
kind of been
an advocation of his and where was this
this was in new jersey was born in new
jersey right and there were collective
type farms in new jersey right and his
father to make a living had to give up
the farm so to speak and
he became a pharmacist in philadelphia
and and george was raised by
an aunt for the most part
he said she was one of these modern
women she smoked it all and all that
what amazes me about
the situation i was jolted when he was
talking about the mccarthy situation
so many people with zelda's background
were really pillory by mccarthy and all
and his ilk
people who did actually much less in a
way than seldis did that's still a
curious question do you have a feel for
that well i don't know seldis is a
difficult person to pin down he
i think he was just real elusive before
the committee and was able to kind of
well he
he has a kind of warmth about him that
can disarm people
and i think he had that effect on the
committee itself
i wonder if the fact that he was purely
a journalistic muckraker rather than a
dynamic activist
had something to do with it yeah i don't
know where the line between you know
being a a purely
journalistic muckraker and a dynamic
activist is i mean
he sure his work sure
ended up
being the ammunition for a whole lot of
other people who were in the fray
i guess that's the
value of a muckraker then that's the
value of the muckraker
you know
and from other sources uh
ralph nader says that at age 14 he began
devouring in fact
and in fact had a great influence on him
daniel ellsberg recalls reading it a
jack anderson the muckraker columnist of
this
generation said he cut his teeth
on on george zelda's work iaf stone
whose own weekly
came after
george seldis
said he got the mailing list from from
from zelda's when
in fact end up closing up shop in 1950
in fact carrie mcwilliams the now late
editor of the nation
says that seldis is clearly one of the
top
10
greatest muckrakers in the history of
america but other names people like
upton sinclair
and ralph nader and and the like
well they're known but he's
he's lived in the celtics has lived in
the shadows i think he feels a little
bitter about that i don't think he lets
on about that until this day still this
giant in our midst is ignored by the
media correct whereas nader and all
these other people still get
a lot of attention
well he obviously uh ran interference
for these people in a time when it was
much more difficult like for instance i
think a lot of the stories you now see
about
the trust and big business i mean you
only have to watch 60 minutes or
abcs 2020 or documentaries or for that
matter even the evening news to see that
these stories are becoming fairly
routine that kind of muckraker but when
zelda started out
it was akin to professional suicide for
a reporter to touch those kinds of
stories and he did it
and that took tremendous courage
are you saying then you agree with
zeldas when he said that the press is
much better today than it used to be oh
i think that exposing well we only have
to look at it i mean three mile island
nuclear power
workplace accidents
[Music]
keep home
the pinto the defects and the pinto i
think these kinds of things get a fairly
uh wide exposure on television today but
i think it's more subtle today than it
used to be last when in his time they
would just either ignore it or severely
distort it
but nowadays they the media do
they mention something like that but the
distortion and the censorship is is more
subtle
still
the press back in the 40s and 30s would
have been outraged even at what
exposes there are in the press today but
it's still far different otherwise we
wouldn't have a need for an alternative
press like we do today yeah clearly but
we have a different agenda to work with
i mean
his times
the issues were a hell of a lot more
clear cut in black and white
as now where i think we're dealing with
the problem that okay
so um so kepone the dangers of uh
chemicals and the food do get a play on
the evening news that's a minute and a
half
out of a 22 minute broadcast
once in a while
and a lot of these stories get lost in
the garbage
absolutely well i can think of
for instance the
recent metcalf committee expose showing
the interlocking directorates and the
great concentration of ownership of the
uh
of a few investors 21 investors
controlling the major
corporations in the country and the
interlocking directorates among all this
cbs evening news was the only one that
had anything on it was 30 seconds on
saturday afternoon
this to me is the difference they may
say a little bit but that's all
and there are things like enceladus
headlines about the concentration camps
that are in the united states
this isn't talked about on the regular
media although a recent
article in seven days well recent within
the last year talked about
that the concentration camps in the
united states are still in existence
so
it isn't as black and white like you say
as it used to be yeah i don't think it's
like anything else i think we should uh
in many ways
pat our give ourselves and those that
came before us like like george seldis
who got us to the middle of the mountain
but it's our
our task our existential task our
political past to keep climbing up to
the top of the mountain
okay we'll take our oxygen and that's a
long
jackets
hard
us but people like that got us there and
they inspire us to to move on and they
should get the recognition they they
deserve and appreciation yes
i enjoyed the story
you know there are a lot of
anti-mccarthy people who say i give
mccarthy a square deal i'll tell the
truth i hate him
i exposed him i said he was a crook he
was a crook as a tail gunner he took
money that he didn't declare in his
income tax
there was a a union man who was going to
organize
legion posts of only union men
to counteract them and he
he was one of the people who worked with
in fact for several years
throughout our 10-year history we
cooperated
with the labor unions
uh the cio news lend the code he just
was talking
i mean we sent them news they sent us
news the railroad workers had a paper
called labor you know the railroad
workers are sort of the aristocrats
believers but they always uh keating was
the editor he was one of my great
friends we always cooperated
uh
buckminster was that the name the
rubber
united rubber workers akron
then came the oil workers in texas you
see
now they did something this late these
labor people did something no one else
did for us i don't know we would never
ask them anyone to do it but they came
across and said we are taking at that
time was only 50 cents a year for 50
copies of that you know we're taking 50
cents out of the annual pay of our
union dues well they probably took do
other things for other things didn't
they it's a it's a system of yeah but
that i don't think labor likes very much
check off so do is check off yes it's an
assessment that's about 50 cents for a
year and you will get a weekly
publication say devoted to our side
well it so happened that we had
we had always one third one third of our
subscribers was labor unions when we had
ten when we had thirty thousand there
were tenth well we had 176 000 we had
fifty sixty thousand for labor there's
no question of it now
we had commonly oil workers cio were
there in texas
i don't know we had
fort arthur
we had tidewater i remember when one
union after another we'd get a block you
see 50 cents for so many hundred people
per each you divide sums of money and we
eventually had thousands
but practically every union man and
every oil union man in texas was one of
my readers a man i think his name was
knight was the president
of the oil workers union he would send
me he would send me telegrams send me
everything you have about the past
history of labor as concerning the
tidewater oil company or gulf or
whatever the texas companies were and of
course i'd send it to him and so on
trace back the word conservative all the
way back you know and see what people
have said about it you know
i mean how people dare call themselves
conservative if only
they knew
that all the way back to greek and roman
times and certainly and all the
all the leaders who everybody
uh looks up to today their views of
conservative conservatives have they've
conserved what the status quo they've
conserved they've considered their
wealth their status and all like that
they've done nothing for progress
all the progress in the world has been
made by anti-conservatives
well do you know what bertolt wreck said
about conservatism so is it a good quote
you write it out for me well he says by
nature i am a conservative man it's
rapids capitalism that makes me a
radical
that's very that's a brilliant
i have a short post script to our
program series on george zelda
our original taping of the interviews
with him
was made two years ago when he was 90
years old
and i've just found out that a new book
is coming out on the market
it is an expose a muckraking expose on
public relations in the united states
and the author is
92 year old george zeldas
you